So, let's start out what we know first. We know what we want to test. So, I'll
go into the plot tester and I'll create a new plot of the size that we did the
example for. And then, I'll print out the actual which should be the number of
fields, if the radius is 400. And then, I'll print out the expected number that
we calculated, which was 8. Now, to actually do the calculation, first thing I
do is calculate the number of rows, which should be an int. And the way that we
did that was to calculate the length minus the diameter, divided by the radius
times the square root of 3. But that wasn't counting the first row, so I've
gotta add the first row back. And since there are some doubles in here, I won't
automatically get integer division. So, to drop the fractional part, I'll need
to actually cast this. Now, I haven't actually defined diameter. But that's
just twice the radius. After that, I calculated the number of odd rows. Which
was the total number of rows, plus one, divided by two. And the number of even
rows, was just n rows over two. The number of columns in each odd row, was
based on the width and the diameter. I want to make sure that I actually get an
int here. So, I notice that the width is an int and the diameter is also an
int. So, that's good. The column is an even row was the width, but we couldn't
use that first space at the left. So, we have to subtract off one radius before
we divide to see how many diameters fit across. And then, the total number of
fields is the odd rows times the number of columns per odd row. And then, the
number of even rows times the number of columns per even row and this number of
fields is what we wanted to return. Let's find all my typos, oh got lucky that
time. Let's see if the plot tester agrees, look's like it at least works for
the example we checked. That's a good sign. That was a pretty tricky problem.
If you struggled, way to stick with it.